with dignity and respect
committed to free speech sense and
entertaining straight-talking
and direct we may each other hello and
welcome to a brand new season of the
pledge it's a new year a new decade and
for many of us a new chance to make new
year's resolutions we absolutely won't
break this year while some people are
dusting off gym leggings that haven't
been worn since last January others are
taking on a whole new challenge brace
yourself Nick Vig annually and with milk
cheese meat and fish all off the menu
it's no surprise that have a go vegans
rejoiced earlier this week when fast
food chain Burger King introduced its
very own plant-based burger the rebel
whopper but their excitement was
short-lived
as in a twist like no other it turns out
the soy sandwich is cooked on the same
grill as the beef burgers making it not
suitable for vegans or even vegetarians
well there's always next year
a coming up Greg thinks president Trump
is playing a dangerous game Michelle
says labour needs to face up to reality
fehmi's had enough of the fat cats in
finance and I want politicians to take
real action on climate change but first
it's Nick
a senior royal quits of the firm for a
life away from the spotlight with a
divorced American they love never heard
that before
alright it might not quite be on the
scale of the abdication crisis but make
no mistake Prince Harry and Megan's
shocked decision to step down will rock
the House of Windsor to its core 20
months ago a nation rejoiced as this
fairytale couple were married and we
watched as the British royal family an
institution that dates back to a time
before even Greg was born came bang up
to date by welcoming
a stunning woman of mixed heritage into
their ranks this couple have claim
they've modernized the institution and
now as part of that they'll split their
time between the UK and North America
and quotes work to become financially
independent don't make me laugh
Harry has given a little over two
million pounds from Prince Charles's
funds we've just spent 2.4 million
pounds doing up there cottage in Windsor
they're reported to have said they want
to keep that house and I assume the
protection teams we provide and pay six
hundred thousand pounds each year for
how is he going to achieve that on the
salary of a left tenon in the household
cavalry cry Harry for England and by
George just what's made you go from
bloke to work okay we can complain that
they haven't that they haven't used the
money that there's tax minus payers
money properly we can complain that
maybe he should have told the Queen
before he did this but the question of
whether or not they were right to leave
I mean look at the Daily Mail they ran
an article that said is Megan's favorite
snack fueling drought and murder because
she happens to eat avocado on toast to
suggest that the press has given her a
fair time is simply not true
so that for them to make the decision to
step away from a life where they're
going to be constantly and unfairly
criticized in the press and hounded is a
completely understandable and human
thing to do how are they hounded they've
just been had an understandably a six
week break in which not one in British
media institution tried to follow them
how's that house at home did them a
little bit harder for the vote for the
past two years I just mentioned can you
can you is that it would you say that's
a fair odds for me how are they going to
avoid media scrutiny when they've
decided to become a list international
celebrities rather than working members
of the firm in precedence two working
members of the firm because I think that
their idea that they can be both HRH
and commercial paid speakers or
presenters or whatever they want to do
to advance their causes which are all
I'm sure extremely admirable I think
that this is an example of have one
to have your cake and eat it that just
cannot obtain in a constitutional
monarchy where your your job title is
your job your title I should say if
you're Kate Middleton is a princess you
can't go out and monetize that but
haven't they actually decided to go
full-time full-time leaving the final
time and to be very interesting to see
where they send the child to school all
those things but I have imagined decided
they don't like it they don't like the
life that they they've got he as we've
discussed here before he's always had a
tough time because yes Mother's Day
she's coming she's why are we putting up
with this and I think they've spent six
weeks in character thinking what they're
going to do and this is at the point if
they want to live independent
financially well then they're going to
have to market the Sussex brand work you
can't switch that on and off as Rachel
says can you great if you're branching
to see if they're allowed to retain the
HRH title because I don't think that the
queen of a crime will want to see that
used as a cert in a commercial the way
we wasn't pretend this is anything like
the abdication the edification was when
the the next king shall abdicate this
guy is now sixteen nine he was for a
long time of course second in a second
yes he's now sixth in line does it
really matter what Michele is there such
a thing as duty or is your duty to your
wife and your child and your infant son
well I think it must be incredibly hard
to be born into such a predicament where
it doesn't matter what you want or dirt
one you are just the focus of something
you're gonna have attention scrutiny and
Fermi is right these guys have been
attacked and scrutinized and unfairly in
many cases just absolutely focused on
and it must be incredibly hard but my
problem with their announcement which by
the way I don't think the Queen was
privy to them doing so before they
actually announced that this is what
we're going to do is to me I do feel a
little bit like they want it all into
Rachael's point you want your care can
eat it because
fair enough if you want to go and
disappear into the ether and be left
alone to do your own thing I understand
why you might want to do that and
certainly for them and why they'd want
to do that well you can't be doing that
on the one hand while Sun simul Taney's
we're saying we're gonna split our time
between the UK and North America living
in this property can you change the
cottage do they you got you can't agree
with her
no-no-no if you're going then you go and
you give up all that goes with it you
can't just keep the best thing could we
not be a little bit fair if they had
chosen to completely abandon everything
in the UK there would be outrage at that
how can you completely abandon out of
your country the royal family etc I see
let's not be unfair I think if he
suddenly said I'm going to call up we're
going to call ourselves the Wales's or
whatever and that's it we're going to
live in a log cabin in Winnipeg it might
be different for those who might have
landed from a different planet let me
just say what this announcement was from
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex after
many months of reflection and internal
discussions we've chosen to make a
transition this year and starting to
carve out a progressive new role within
this institution we intend to step back
as senior members of the royal family
and work to become financially
independent while continuing to fully
support Her Majesty the Queen we now
plan to balance our time between the
United Kingdom and North America
continuing to honor our duty to the
Queen the Commonwealth and our patron
ages and just to finish buckin
buckingham palace responded discussions
with the duke and duchess of sussex are
at an early stage we understand their
desire to take a different approach but
these are complicated issues that we
will take time to work through I mean I
agree we're going to hear a bit from
Angela Levin who's a royal historian but
I think that when we all feel we have
our inalienable personal sovereignty but
I'm afraid if you're in a member of the
royal family I don't think that applies
you don't you're born into this and your
duty to your was that's arguable but
let's hear from Angela Levin to see what
the Queen might have how the Queen might
have responded the Queen will be very
upset and I think that she possibly
doesn't have really the courage or the
willpower to deal with these sort of
issues at her age her whole aim in life
has been Duty and for the royal family
to continue but you know Harry is an
individual who can make his choice the
fact he's now six in line mean that he
doesn't go to all these state events as
he would do if he was higher up I think
it all comes down to money when Harry
was isn't inside the firm he's
controlled by the firm he can't make
money outside the firm this absolutely
opens up a Pandora's box which is why
the Queen has no idea in the way
how to react yet this will take a long
time to work out presumably he'll
continue to get a couple of million in
the year that his father gives to the
two boys she could easily go back if she
can learn Haneda where most of a lot of
American series are made because of the
tax breaks she could go back to acting
and she would be she would earn an awful
lot of money they can have another life
and I think they've chosen and that's
what they're gonna let brackets and we
must respect this if if megan has helped
Harry unlock the demons from losing his
mum being forced to walk behind the gun
carriage at his mother's funeral and
this man clearly has had emotional
issues if he just can't put up with the
flashbulbs then we have to respect that
and we have to allow under step away I
just absolutely can concur with what
rachel says then you have to fully well
you can't have it it's not they can eat
it what's gonna happen I mean this is
this is a transitional state if they do
lose all that royal luster all the
titles all the association what is the
Sussex brand then I mean what is Harry
he's as you say leftenant
not even serving though Megan has
retired from acting what do they do but
that would have happened anyway to have
it because as he gets older and another
generation of Royals come through that
are than a Williams children he becomes
less important and as his Hollywood
taking trying to seek the control they
enjoy Hollywood stars and they're not
getting in the Royals Michelle well I
just think this has been announced a bit
too early because to me there seems to
be so much that needs to be fought
through you know you've just announced
they're about the booking and palace
statement and as I mentioned I don't
think the Queen was privy to this Devon
I wouldn't you sat down as a family and
gone right this is what we're gonna do
how is it going to work let's do a
collective joint statement and then all
of these questions and quantifications
about how they're going to keep the
titles and what about this that I'd just
be mu and assumably they made up their
minds and they don't want the pressure
that would come on them from the rest of
the family to change that yeah this is
what they've decided to do but then you
go to you family this is what we do an
end of story
so you got to see your granny every time
you wanted to change your life again
yeah
but what's so weird is he can resign
from his own family I mean where none of
us are in that we can't but he appears
to be but most people's families aren't
actual businesses though with the with
the media scrutiny that comes along with
that it's totally reasonable but you
want 1.8 billion pounds in tourism that
the fact that you are a family and
you're on show and you're you have your
duties to perform brings to the nation
every year has shown do you think making
us change Terry for the good or the bad
or no difference at all I don't know I
think that when you become a partnership
things do change you wherever you are
and I do think I've always and I've said
on this show
I've always felt sorry for Harry because
going behind the back off that's your
mom it's doesn't matter what you know
towards it's the the Queen and Princess
and Princess it's your mum and to do
that in front of such a public audience
and to have lost your mum in that way
you know he's always had an
uncomfortable relationship with the
press for example as well hasn't it all
agrees there's some sympathy for